marijuana use and athletic competition
it's the controversial combination
sparking debate all across the country
once again
following the banning of an olympic
hopeful after she used marijuana
so what's right and what's wrong marco
mana joining us now live tonight with a
closer look
orco well denise many say as times
change
so should rules for athletes but what
makes things more complicated is that
different sports and different levels of
sport have
different standards recently she lost
her opportunity to compete in the
olympics
track sprinter shikari richardson was
suspended for a month after testing
positive for marijuana at the olympic
trials
her absence from the games reigniting
the debate over the use of marijuana by
athletes
i think that's insanity ufc fighters are
weighing in
especially with recent developments in
their sport the nevada athletic
commission recently voted to remove the
rule that would find or suspend fighters
for testing positive for marijuana
athletes who smoke pot say this is a
step forward
but they'll still stay clean for fights
i'm excited for after but yeah
nothing changes there for me i'll
probably continue to do two weeks
out even those who don't smoke welcomed
the news
are you injuring anyone and are you
taking an unfair advantage
no then it's not my concern what you're
up to so what does the science say
a 2018 study shows quote there was no
evidence for cannabis use as a
performance enhancing drug but the u.s
anti-doping agency says it can be for
some athletes and sports disciplines
i just hope that everybody gets on the
same page
girl clothing ceo courtney olsen
sponsors some ufc fighters as a
recovering addict she says she would not
drop
athletes who use marijuana for health
reasons i would rather see
people utilizing things like medical
marijuana
as opposed to xanax or valium
which has a way higher addiction
proposition
now research into marijuana's impact on
athletic performance
is still ongoing but there is research
that does suggest
that cannabis can help with pain
management and recovery
reporting live in las vegas tonight orca
mana 8 news now